Sleep well tonight, my boy. I think you've overdone it a little bit today.
Well, maybe, yes.
We were in the wood, bird spotting for most of the afternoon, and it was great fun.
Then Mr. Brown said we could climb his tree and pick some apples.
Oh, and this morning at school, teacher told us all about the sea and about the big fissures.
You'll be fine tomorrow.
Sleep tight.
Dreams, Peter.
Messages, Speedy?
Just saucy.
Sleep.
We can put our feet up with no outside signal.
Well, that's all right for some of us, but the brain cells are always on duty.
Is that right, Meister?
Hmm.
Oh, yes, that's perfectly correct.
Even though you may be fast asleep, your memory is sifting through piles of information.
To the right, this can fly.
Rots have always got wings.
Apples should be round.
And red, some apples are green.
Apples, that's in order.
And what about red blood?
Fine.
Then we've got green apples and green blood.
What?
That's just not on.
I wonder what blithering idiot could have dreamed up green blood of all things.
Out!
Apples may be green or red, but there's only one colour for blood.
Come along with me and we'll find a place for you.
Birds can fly, that's good. Birds can be blue, okay.
Birds have nests, quite correct.
Birds have pin feathers, yes. Birds have pen feathers.
What? I've never heard of pen feathers.
Out!
You've been misfiled, son. No need to get upset.
Just come along with me now.
I'll find you a place down in the pen and ink section.
You've got nothing to do with birds, really.
Chief, it's a little ink card, okay?
Hey, don't forget, ink's black as well.
Look over here. What do you make of this one, Chief?
Never seen one like that before. I haven't the faintest idea.
Wait over there. It's chalk.
Yes, chalk is white and chalk and white.
This sifting and sorting is boring and takes forever. Why don't we have some fun in the meantime?
Let's play a little game then, guys.
Why don't we rather make up a dream? We've got everything we need right here.
It's a dream.
Well, we sort of mix up all kinds of memories. Higgledy-piggledy.
It's a fantasy, you see.
And we can do things that are impossible in real life.
You've got no idea what fun it is.
Let's see.
We've got an apple, a bird, a tree, and a whole wood.
Is that enough to make a dream?
It's plenty, but we can do a lot better by adding some old memories.
What do you say, fellas?
Thus, can they come too?
Of course.
Mr. Bird, tell me what the next stop is, would you?
What? You'll be amazed, my son.
Lord and Master, I swear fealty to thee, most excellent Duke of Nervdom.
This crown and rule over thy faithful subjects as supreme monarch.
Huh?
Maestro, please wake up right away. The dream's over.
Maestro, look there!
Except, what on earth's going on here? Why did you wake me up?
The dream is over, Maestro, but he's gone back to sleep.
That's perfectly all right. In fact, there was no need to wake me up for that. It wasn't an emergency.
Now, the brain can get back to the task of sorting out all the information, and we might even dream again.
Talking about young Peter, of course, not myself.
He has got the advantage of youth.
It takes him no time at all to drop off to sleep,
whereas with an old fellow like me,
once he's been woken up in the weird mode...
Cloud here, but dear me, I've forgotten where we're supposed to put them.
Sorry, I'm stuck too.
Where on earth can I put this lightning bolt?
You could file it under heat, light, or electricity.
This thing flies, but it's no bird.
More like a mouse with wings.
Look out here, beautiful eyes, old owl!
And the big bad wolf.
Darling, it was only a bad dream.
A lot of mixed up memories, that's...
Why does it made something like that be only a dream?
Your body goes on working while you're asleep.
Heart keeps on pumping blood round the body.
And your brain doesn't shut down for the night.
It's busy by sorting out all kinds of impressions.
And sometimes it gets them muddled up.
It can cause a nightmare.
It's a good job we don't dream every night, Mum.
Oh, but we do dream every night, my darling.
It's just that we forget our dreams, that's all.
Nobody knows exactly how dreams work, Peter, but they help to keep us healthy.
More nightmares for you, only sweet dreams from now on.
Blood vessels bring oxygen to Peter's brain cells,
which burn this gas for energy and send back carbon dioxide into the bloodstream.
Dear young fellow, perhaps I should point out to you at the risk of being found oppressively informative
that the bubble which you so impetuously kicked is not light oxygen, as you assumed, but heavy carbon dioxide.
It might not be a bad idea to take it along to the lungs and exchange it for a bubble of oxygen.
Sir Globus, I remember what you told us about the body when it sleeps.
It goes on using oxygen even though it's unconscious.
So you see, I do listen to what you say.
The last one I need for a full load of oxygen.
Mitochondria needs some energy.
Mitochondrium plant number 227.
Are you listening or not?
That's quite right.
Sorry I can't stick around to play yo-yos,
but this oxygen is needed urgently and I'm in a hurry.
Bye.
Not before time.
Some of us take our jobs seriously, you know.
Nobody cares about us night shift workers.
They don't even know we exist, and I'm still waiting for my sugar.
I'm expected to produce miracles, keep this furnace going.
What am I to burn in it, horse feathers?
Ah, am I by any chance invisible?
Come on, maestro.
Oh, it's just routine repairs and maintenance.
Even while the body's asleep, are the parts wearing out?
Parts are always wearing out.
The whole body needs to be repaired constantly,
and the best time to carry out repairs is when the body isn't so busy.
When it's asleep.
Stop!
Can't accept any deliveries. The furnace is out of order.
Well, I'm sorry, but I've got my orders. What am I supposed to do now? Wait.
You'd better take your loads, the pair of you, and go and drop them off at some other furnace that's in working order.
What do you expect me to do? Just look at it.
This store's had it. We'll have to fit a new one, I'm afraid.
Here, Chief. There's a big crack in the wall. It's bad.
We need lots of protein to fix that. You'd better order some.
Doesn't work anymore.
We'll fix it or get a new one, Peter. Nothing lasts forever.
This water pipe's completely bunged up.
Everything gets bunged up if you give it enough time
It's new
Oh no, not quite as good as new
Sir, I want you to remember that
Even though you repair things, they're bound to wear out completely in the end
That, the ribosomes have all become discombobulated
In assembly lines of this cell, protein production has broken down completely
This is a disaster, we'll just have to wake him
Alright, alright, I'll do it
Maestro, maestro
Problem on our hands, maestro
Ribosome assembly lines have broken down
And the RNA codes are getting scrambled.
Tell us what to do, maestro.
The human body is like a house.
It has to be built first of all, then it has to be maintained.
Because parts wear out and they have to be replaced.
What's next, then?
I'll tell you what's next.
A few repairs and renovations.
The body you'll find has an amazing capacity for renewing and healing itself.
So let's get to work, shall we?
The RNA instructions for assembling proteins are all scrambled.
I want you to get some repair enzymes down there right away and clear up the mess.
That's all for the moment. Get going.
I don't think we'll ever get this straightened out, Mr. Supervisor.
Come on. I've got the plans. We can get to work now.
Separate C and G. Right. Good.
Now we can put the C over here, okay, which gives us A-C-C-G-U.
It's fine. It's what it says here as well.
Oi, we need some glue over here.
I refuse to sit next to him. He's horrid. Bye.
Put him in there. He's not a C.
C.
The C one ran away.
It has to be a C, I think.
If you change the message, it could lead to something serious!
I haven't got time to worry about that! Look at the work piling up!
What's the meaning of this?
That it's not my fault!
How can you say that when you stuck them together?
You were the one who did the cutting!
Please stop arguing and fix it!
Know what you've just done! You've created wild genes, you have!
Wild genes, did you say? What do they do?
Wild genes? Oh, this could be very serious!
Yes, I'll mix up the message!
Wild genes? This could be disastrous!
That's just what I was afraid of, Maestro!
You took the word straight out of my mouth.
Judge! Too late already.
We must hope that it won't be too bad.
It was to be expected, actually.
No matter how many times you repair something,
it's going to go seriously wrong at some stage or a whole thumbs.
Well, here we are, me hardies, and we're all set for some fun.
Follow me!
We can deal with those pilot proteins by producing enzymes to control them,
but we'd better be quick about it before they affect the nervous system.
If it's possible, then there's no harm!
then there's no harm.
It's under control again.
Do you know what simply astonishes me?
The sheer lightning speed of the body's reaction.
No sooner had the body made a mistake by producing harmful proteins
than it corrected its own error with an enzyme which simply wiped them out.
It's fantastic, isn't it, when you consider how swiftly the organism repairs itself.
How many machines, I ask you, are capable of repairing themselves?
The human body is more wonderful than any of man's inventions.
Now let's run down our checklist, shall we?
Mitochondria, okay.
Ribosomes, okay.
circulation okay heart okay all systems go everything's back to normal maestro that's
exactly what i was expecting we've just seen how quickly a young organism can repair damage to
itself but things are different with older people why is that maestro because the cells get worn out
you simply can't go on repairing them indefinitely that's out of the question each cell wears out
and so does the whole body normal wear and tear takes its toll as well as abnormal damage in the
case of those who abuse their bodies, then there's damage resulting from the body's own mistakes.
Heparin, for example, has its uses, but it has to be eliminated when it tries to stop the healing
process. Then there's the never-ending battle against alien invaders, which is very tiring for
you. And in the long run, it's the entire construction, the whole body, which becomes
more difficult to keep in good condition and takes longer to repair. Then one day, alas,
it wears out completely. That's like you, Meister. With us.
Oh, no, Peter. I'm long past the age for playing football. It's a pity, but there it is.
Pa, why is there an age for playing football and an age for not playing it?
Peter, you've got all the time you need to find out the answer to that question.